I turned my camera on I cut my fingers
on the
way
was um yeah I'm really happy to be here
and I try to remember when I've been in
Asia for the first time and it's super
funny cuz actually exactly 10 years ago
I did my first trip to Japan so it was
on 20th November 2004 and I took this
picture with my moac
cam uh it was my birthday and if you can
count you might guess okay it's my
birthday today so I'm quite happy to be
here uh I used this ENT entity doomo
Japanese phone to take a picture and it
was like 320 * 240 and it was a really
amazing resolution that time
it's totally crazy and if you try to
remember it was uh it's 10 years and
there was no iPhone there was no YouTube
there wasn't Google Maps there was
nothing
yeah
uh but there was something on the server
side so JS we heard about this uh you
can use it in website but there was
already already like four or five years
uh where Hammer was in ction so we used
this on our servers not sure if anyone
have ever used it but it was a cool
JavaScript framework that you can run on
the
browser and yeah so 10 years ago now
this conference somehow combines all
this stuff and I'm going to talk about
me um I'm Martin klepper you can find me
on Twitter at
MK um I have my own company called uaps
we are uh located in Hamburg and do all
different kind of mapping related uh
yeah coding so we analyze code this is
for example like we we calculate how far
you can travel in a specific time um we
also work a lot for the Google Maps team
in Mountain View creating like imagery
if you have the latest and Android uh
lollipop for example they use our
backgrounds for the system um and we do
stuff like this so I'm working during
the day all time using the Google Maps
API um but this talk will not be about
my daily job this will be more about my
second um Second Life during the dark um
this is me how I look at night and I
have a website uh it's called
m1k um where you can find all my
Productions and I might ask if you maybe
can shut down this this uh this other
screen because the next slide will be
full of code and that's I think it's
important to to see all of them no not
this one but the the small
one get it back okay thanks um yeah
about a year ago I presented a thing
that's called the world and it was a
production that looks like this in the
source code so this is the actual source
code of the project it was exactly 1K of
um JavaScript so, 24 bytes and if you
run this you see this in the browser so
it's showing you a spinning world and
the code itself is executing and
modifying itself and it's called aine
and it it shows you like a spinning
clob um another thing I did is the man
code so this is the the code itself you
see there's a preag the script and once
you have this in the browser you see
this so it outputs itself and as soon as
you click it it dives into the code and
shows you an animated Mand for for about
a minute um where it really zooms deep
into the the specific details uh until
you reach a limit where you can't have
the the resolution of the numbers that
are use in in JavaScript anymore so it
breaks and getting jty and uh you see
this in a moment um where the where the
code itself breaks apart because the
resolution is not high
enough yeah I can watch this forever but
there there's a there's a time where so
it certainly stops now you see this now
the numbers are not accurate anymore and
it
breaks um another thing I did is
jazz.com you might have heard about this
um there were some ideas of this before
and there were some working ex or not
working examples but someone proved that
you only need six different characters
these six different characters to
actually write any kind of or any code
in JavaScript that you want um what I
did I fixed it
work make it work for node for example
and put a website only where you have an
input text where you can say okay give
me lot one and it outputs you this prets
plus and ENT code and you can take this
without the compiler put it in the
consoler and it gives you a l
one so this is the code that you have to
copy uh yeah quite
amazing I'm not going to show you how I
work with this kind of samples how to
Minify um HTML how to Minify JavaScript
code and after this I'm going to show
you some more examples and something
newer I did especially for this
conference but let's start with the HTML
or better it's Dynamic HTML 5 so it's
the best of like the old in the New
World um if you have this template um
and have a look at this and really think
about what is needed here to make
something work
uh then we can figure out okay we don't
need the doc type we can skip this um
the HTML TXS the surrounding um needed
we can skip them um if we have a body
and include something before the body
it's automatically placed in the Hat so
we don't need this uh if we do a
production and don't want to have a
title we skip this um if we have a
script and specify the type text
JavaScript we actually can skip the type
because whenever you don't specify the
type the browser will guess it's
JavaScript so reduce this um and then we
have the unload Handler which CS the in
it if we don't want to use this we
simply put the script at the end of the
button uh the body sorry or we can place
it in the onload Handler
itself and if we do this then the body
the closing body tag isn't needed
anymore so we can skip this and only
have that
looks
short there there's a there's a way to
get it shorter so you see this quotes
and then you have the the the text
itself or the the code that's executed
and if there ain't no quotes in there
you actually can skip the quotes and
just say it like that so this would be
the shortest form of like having
something running in a browser or like
having JavaScript executed in in a
browser um in my examples I don't want
to like show a dialogue only I wanted to
modify the HTML itself so I need
something to manipulate the the document
so one way would be to say document
right um if you want to have an
animation this doesn't work because it's
always a pan stuff to the body um so we
can say document body in a HTML is
something one for example and to get
this shorter we can actually assign an
ID to the body
and and once once you do it you have
access to this ID so this is a global
thing that's available or someone call
it a shinger variable so sometimes it's
there sometime not but actually there
there's not there's no need to use
document get um get element by ID or
uses Jack gra syntax and you can simply
access this without calling them um if
we want if you want this to be like
monos space B we have to use a preag or
something like that to make it like all
fixed with and if you look at this you
might see there's a problem because the
browser thinks okay I'm going to close
here the the tag and it will only show
the plus one and doesn't execute the
code uh to fix this we have to get back
the quotes um and then if you look at
this there's the space between the ID
and onload uh attribute and if if you
simply replace or not replace but switch
the order then we can skip the space and
make it like one character
short this is the things that that you
have to know but yeah it's quite fun um
it looks short but actually if we
totally switch this around there might
be an easier way or not an easier but a
shorter way to get it and uh now we say
only a preag with an ID and some script
after that this is like one character
shorter than the version before
uh and if you really read the specs
there's something that might be not that
much known or not well known it's the uh
tet type tag uh it's somewhat like the
preag but doesn't have this um it's an
inline monospaced tag or if you don't
care about formatic you can choose
whatever you want for for example Tech X
the browser will run it but it's like
not mon space them
yeah so this was HTML now we're Go to
JavaScript
um I put together this really simple
example so we have X Y and Z and we have
math random and get the maximum of both
values uh we can skip the RAS if you
don't care about global leaks um we can
assign ma to a variable M and reuse this
and we can do the same for the random
method and use this and now it's getting
interesting because we could also say
Okay R is the string random and access
this using the square brackets on math
itself it's actually longer but once you
have a look at this you can move the r
thing inside of the first accessor and
store this in the r and we use it for
the next time so this is shorter than
than the version
before um
or we could use evil things like with uh
withm and simply call the random methods
on there and once you do this you can
skip the um the curly brackets if you
use commas and do the same thck that
that we've done before and if you place
this in one line we have this at the end
so this is like to give you an idea how
to reduce the code step by step to get
it really
down
um
okay some more examples um I was like
trying different
things
sorry and I realized that once you have
like tiny code it's totally cool to do
something like what I call the Death
Star um you can actually put spaces
where you want and make this align
somehow and this is is an HTML page and
this is like a valid HTML it's not it
has Global leaks of course um but it's a
valid HTML um page that you can run in
your browser and it will execute an
alert which says xss and if you look
close um there's the body unload in the
top and all the rest is like um code
that's written Inc so the the Russian
alphabet and it will give you an alert
that's looking at
this um I played around with different
things and I was the first I think who
uses Hew to write JavaScript and
actually you have to flip this so you
read it from right to left uh so you see
some assignments and it goes down and it
also gives you an alert one in a br it's
quite funny and if you focus on this you
realize okay you have to think different
and if you want to check this out on a
website type in this URL but remember to
uh do it by right to left or use the
shortcut Hebrew to to get there yeah in
asrian Asia I also did some experiments
that I want to show it's like half a
year ago or something like this where I
Ed Japanese Katakana characters and I
also like wrote something it's always
the same basically but once you lay out
this thing you can create something that
looks like it's written from top to down
so these looks like columns but actually
I use tabs to align them and um the the
impression that you get is that that you
have different columns but you can copy
this one by one into the console and
gives you anog
one yeah quite cool but once you look
too much into this kind of code um you
might see oops sorry go back because
this is
important
sorry my doesn't handle movies anymore
that good so let's check this out okay
so once you stay at the codes you
realize okay you're somehow lost into
into the metrix and uh it's crazy
yeah this is important as I said because
I wanted to create something that looks
like the Matrix so if you if you have a
look at this reigning code thing then
you realize okay this is source code
somewh but it doesn't look doesn't use
Latin characters it uses some Asian
characters and numbers and that's it so
I did a research and um yeah I always
start like by by Googling cool project
that used this the same idea and I found
found some something by Ryan
H and he did this nice canvas animation
where you have this code coming coming
down and I had a look at the code which
was really well written and optimized
already and the basic idea here was to
okay have something fil Style
green then add some characters at
specific positions and then to to get
this effect he sets the FI style to um
something black but with a really low
opacity and put an this black uh thing
on top of it so once you done this in an
animation you see it's getting like
darker and darker but you still have the
thing in the background and if you look
at the code you see okay there's some uh
some repeating things that you can get
out and he actually put everything in a
in a in a string and replace this um
with what we seen
before the code itself is only
352 characters long and I did what I'm
good at and reduced it by about 100
characters to have the same effect and I
added something back to it so some cool
things that I missed for example I use
different characters I use um also white
flashing characters and I have something
metrix like an attack in in a button and
the final thing will look like this
somehow I leter show you this an
animation or how it works but first
let's have a look at the code so this is
the code and once
you read this you realize okay there are
so many like Latin characters or English
words that we use here and I asked
myself um how do we write JavaScript um
without Latin
characters and this is
fun um there are actually two ways one
way would be to use or in the end is
like mixing both of them one way would
be to use Escape sequences and the other
way would be to play scravel later
explain you what's what this is
about um but if you have an a for
example we can also use um Unicode
Escape sequences and say back SLU and
then put a four digigit hexad dimal code
behind this and in JavaScript it's
interpreted as an a um you can like
combine them and have this for example
if you put this into the consoler run it
it's a lot one so it has the characters
behind and it
executes um that's cool CU it also works
with any unic code characters that you
have for example with this character I
think it's
rain um so it's back
SLU uh
968 um so this would be oneway another
way would be to use um
hexadecimal um writing so you have a
back slash X and then put some hexad DMR
code and the thing is that it's only
working for Strings so it's not working
for regular code and you only allowed to
put in um characters lower than like in
in Sky range so no there's no way to to
express um unic code
characters and one thing most people
don't know about is and then and I came
uh by this like some weeks ago is if you
just have a backslash and um two to
three numbers then it's interpreted as
as um an octal AS sequence so you can
use numbers from zero to uh from Z to
seven seven and have this octal
representation of the ask code and um
this gives you back a
again yeah that's quite cool because
this is the first thing where you don't
have any Latin characters in anymore and
you can combine this into this so um I'm
going to show what's going on on here so
here are like many numbers octal
sequences and Behind These numbers they
are actually strings or like a
combination of characters and if you
place this in one line you see this
thing and this is something really
powerful and um to show you we access
map on an empty array we could also have
like filter or something filter sort
split whatever U but map is really short
thing to use and this is actually a
function and if we have a function we
can access the Constructor of the
function and this is the function
Constructor so and this is I'm not sure
if you know this but you can pass any
kind of strings to a function
Constructor and it will generate a
function for you you can also like put
um arguments in front of this and it
will evaluate once you execute it so
basically what we have here is now an
eval function but we without calling
eval yeah that's super cool and super
powerful okay another way which is quite
fun to use is playing Scrabble with
JavaScript I'm going to explain
you why I call this Scrabble um this is
something really basic so if you you
have an array and you say not array so
if you do a negation then you get fors
back if you do a double negation you get
true back that should be clear if you
then add an empty string to it then you
get the string fors or the string
through and now the fun thing starts
because what you can do is you can
access uh different at different
position different characters so you get
t r u e if you get the first second
third and fourth position and you can
combine them in different orders and
access them uh like put them and access
it on on other
elements um and if we do this for
example fors fors two true one two three
one zero and if you shift this then you
see okay we have alert here and you
combine the strings and you can put this
into the eval method that we seen before
so this is really cool and this is what
I call Grabel so you can you have access
to false object true undefined and
that's enough to like have a couple of
characters and once you have these
characters you can combine them into
like a more bigger sense um the one
thing that you need to get is the
Constructor so this is possible here and
then if you have an array and called a
Constructor it's an function and if you
called a Constructor on the same thing
then you got something to execute your
code so basically what you have here is
the same ability that we've seen
before okay how many time do I have
left 24 minutes
okay um so this will be the the the
final thing that I'm I'm going to show
here uh this is the The Matrix code I
call it rain because it's it's calling
the um raining code sequence and um this
is the source code itself so this is oh
we have the HTML TX we still need this
and you can't replace it with um other
TX but the source code uh is um in asent
letters only and on the top this is
something we have to use here too we
have to Define it's the Char at utf8
otherwise the browser will not like
render this correctly which is a p in my
opinion utf8 should Bea but it is not
but um yeah we have to use it here and
then you see okay we have an ID with the
rain um Ki and we can access this like
this um like we've seen before inside of
the
code this is the JavaScript and if you
might see it from the from the layout
it's like there are different parts here
the the first part is assigning um the
the letters so like grabbing different
letter and instead of storing this into
ABCD I use hun in this case so the first
theana is an empty string then we have a
for through and whatever and then it's
getting the different characters um then
we have something here this is an
encoded string it's and a string that's
later decoded by the code that follows
and it's encoded into KES and the final
thing is to to encode these characters
and give you back the encoded version
that could be evaluated
yeah okay let's start with the uh
encoding
here oh actually it's the decoding so if
we escape this character I think it's
slow the meaning of this um if you
escape this we get back um perent U 61
62 it's like the uni code um uh encoding
thing but but but um perc sign and if we
then replace the percent U with an empty
string we get back just in
numbers so this is the first thing we do
the next would be to split every second
car or like split the whole whole string
by two characters and put an X in front
of this so you get back back slash
x61 back SL
x62 and and if you eval this then you
get back a string in this case AB so
it's quite cool because we have um a uni
code symbol which actually uses like
more than one bite and we can split this
up into two bytes of of L characters and
like encode both of them into this and
the escape and replace logic is only
like several bites
long um another thing that I had to do
is uh four level Inception of eval uh
I'm going to explain this in a moment
but we have some some strange looking
KES in there and the first thing I did
is using this Escape thing and because
we can't get the P out of the Scrabble
thing we have to use the um back
slash um syntax to get the octal version
of this and if you Evol this then you
get back the escape with the replay
thing and if you get back this then you
have what I've explained before and in
the first level we have to El one that
will be
executed yeah it's strange but uh it's
really fun to do
yeah and the final thing will look like
this so this is the first time I'm going
to show this I did some sneak previews
for some friends but um the final
animation is
this
yeah
so it's all done in Thousand characters
or not it's actually it's like 500
characters the btes is like one 1K and
if you really look close and I'm
stopping the animation so this is the
source code itself so it outputs the
source and um uses the canvas to lay out
um symbols to make it look like the
Matrix yeah and you can find this here
or use the Matrix shortcut it will
redirect to to the location and yeah
that's basically it the only question
that most people ask me is why do you do
this not only
when but why and there there many
reasons in my opinion and the five most
important reasons are first of all it's
super fun to do so you you're doing this
and you have fun together with other
people and you think about something and
tweak your own code the next thing is
that
you you see your limits in the first
place but then you know I have to like
bypass these limits I have to look
deeper and uh learn how to do it right
and and you you set your own limits by
this character or amount of characters
or amount of bites and you force
yourself really to think about how to do
it and this is important because you
have to focus on the the the most
easiest idea not not the most easiest
idea but the most easiest
implementation or reduce the idea that
you can do it in this amount of
characters and one thing that you also
learn is like these these hidden parts
of the languages or the language itself
that you usually don't use during your
daytime job you find out more things how
you can use not only hacks but really
useful things um which you might never
have heard
about and it in my opinion brings back
like a really good community so whenever
I put this online with a with I have
this idea to do this people from all
over the world like reply to my TW TW or
I reply to them and people come together
and they hack all together on one single
project and that's super cool yeah and
that's it basically so thanks um I put
together all the slides and um upload
the
presentation and yeah so check out my
website m1k or tweet me at MK and that's
it and we can do some
Q&A thank you Martin
that's really awesome cuz I'm very sure
that apart from Latin characters many of
us know a second language or a third
language that we can play with so any
questions on that maybe you know
Japanese or or other Hebrew characters
that you want to play
with or even JS 1K for the fun of it
like uh Yan was saying because don't do
boring stuff do fun stuff yeah any
questions uh I wonder if the code on the
website is optimal or if you can further
improve the result by hand yeah so the
question was to repeat it um the the JS
F website um it uses the same concept as
you seen before with the Scrabble thing
so it gets characters from somewhere and
puts this together and the question was
if the the code itself is Optimum or
optimized or if you can reduce it
further and as I spent with these kind
of projects for more than year now I see
it I'm pretty sure it can be reduced to
maybe the 1% of the original code So
currently you have this alert one in
about 2,000 characters and once you put
in jar the whole browser will load
because you it can't handle this anymore
and there's an easy way to fix this but
I need some time to do it
yeah
cool yes Joshua of course you did d1k
before
Mar great stuff is youa um actually I
learned a lot of uh JS golfing stuff
from you online um my question is this
um how often do you look at code you
have written in the past and do you
wonder like what do that mean or do you
kind of like keep like the ununified
version
somewhere for for this project or for my
daily work for your I mean for your for
your quotes which you Minify
to to releas yeah so maybe to to
separate I don't use this during my day
job
or just to make clear um and the other
thing is if you want to write this kind
of code the original code has to be
really super strict um like aligned so
it's there's I have some tools where
like um where I get to the modified
version but I always keep the original
code or at least until some point and
then you do some manual optimizations
like shifting characters to to make it
really fit yeah but usually I try to
stay on the road with the original
unmodified version as long as I
can great maybe uh one
more uh just curious have you tried the
image JS before it's like uh loading a
JavaScript uh injecting a JavaScript
into an image file yes i' I've been
working on a project I have this in a
presentation last year I think um there
a cool way to to use a p the PNG format
and the PNG compression of an image to
actually get your code down really well
so it's way better than do it by hand
and you can use repeating string and the
PNG compression algorithm packs this
into an image and you can add something
to the end of the PNG which is actually
HTML and inside of this HTML you put in
some some code and if you load this PNG
as an HTML file and have an image that
loads itself so the PNG you can analyze
this and use this compression it's a
super cool thing
and you should check out my talk from
last
year all right thank you Martin yeah
thank you so
much